- What we've done is we've taken $7,500
from every American, or
16,500 from every taxpayer,
$16,000 from every taxpayer
and then given some of those taxpayers
a check for $1,200, that's not helping.
We've taken two and 1/2 trillion dollars
and only given 355 billion
to small businesses.
Where's the rest going?
Same place it went last time.
(soothing electronic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and
this is the Rubin Report.
Joining me, today is
the founder of TheBlaze,
the host of The Glenn Beck Radio Program
and the author of the new
book, Arguing With Socialists,
Glenn Beck, welcome back
to the Rubin Report.
- Thanks, man, how are you?
- I'm all right, we are in the midst
of a zombie apocalypse.
- (laughing)
- And I'm in the people's
republic of California
so I probably have a shorter
lease on life than you do,
but I'm okay.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm good, I'm glad, New York,
glad I'm not in LA, I moved
to the center of the country
for a reason and this would
be it, this would be it.
- So I guess, the first
obvious question here,
beyond just the general, "How
you doing during corona,"
is as a guy who's been in mainstream media
and out of mainstream media
and a trailblazer in new media,
did you ever think you'd be
doing your show from home,
like Dave Rubin does his
show from home all the time?
- I tell you something Dave, it is,
'cause I've been in broadcast
for like 42 years now,
the technology and what
we can accomplish now,
we couldn't have accomplished
even 10 years ago,
it's phenomenal, it's really
phenomenal how the power
of the media really is in the
hands of the average person
if they care to take it.
It's really crazy.
- So how, treating you in
the middle of the country,
where you are at least a little bit safe?
- Yeah, it's pretty
good, it's pretty good.
It's not New York, thank
God, Texas is still free.
Thank God, we've got a good governor
who is not trying to
tell everybody exactly
what to do, being home with the kids
'cause my kids live next door
so we're kinda quarantined together.
So we got nine of us
living at home.
- Wow.
- This is nice, it's nice.
There's times where you're like,
"Oh, yeah, I gotta get out of here,"
but most most of it is
good, most of it is good.
- So I know we could get
into the numbers about corona
and all of that stuff, but
let's just put that aside,
but let's talk about the
thing that I think mostly
animates almost everything that you
and I do, which is freedom and liberty.
So as we're hearing about
lockdowns being extended
and just in the last couple
of days we heard, now,
in LA where I am, now we're at May 15th
and we know it'll go beyond that
'cause it's not like you just magically
flip the switch
(fingers clicking)
and suddenly we're all out there again
and we see this cascading
across the country.
How concerned are you that,
as we just get more and
more stuck in our homes,
as we don't go out, as we don't socialize,
as we, as you probably saw in Michigan,
you can't buy seeds at stores
to plant your own food,
all of these types of things?
I'm much more concerned about that
than I am the virus specifically.
Are you sort of in line with that
and what do you make of
the whole thing?
- So yeah,
so I said back in January
when we were starting
to look at this and I said,
"This thing is gonna sweep,
"this looks like 1918," I said,
"but what concerns me
is not the death rate,
"what concerns me is what
it will do to the economy
"and what it can do to freedom."
And I think that's turning
out to be accurate.
What the Federal Reserve has done,
what the government has
done is unprecedented
and to really fully understand it
'cause the system of the
free market is so complex
and while it has taken a
beating for the last 20 years,
it is very fragile and it's
as if we were all on a 747,
a brand new Boeing 747,
and the I said, "You know what?
"It's gonna get really,
really bumpy up here,
"so what we're gonna do,
"some of you, maybe one could
get a concussion or die,
"but there are 400 of us on this plane,
"so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna turn the engines off
"and right before we hit the ground,
"we're gonna turn 'em back
on," I wouldn't be for that.
- Ya' think?
- I would say,
maybe a couple people
could bump their head
and maybe we could even
lose a couple of people
on the plane, I hate to say that,
but nobody's ever turned the engines off
in hopes that you turn 'em
on at exactly the right time
before it's just a pile
of rubble on the ground.
And that's what they've done
and I don't know how
effective it's going to be.
They're talking about a v-economy
where they just turn it off
and then pump money into it
to preserve it and then
when you turn it back on,
it goes straight back up.
It won't, it won't go straight back up,
it can't go straight back up.
First of all, you're losing,
80% of jobs that are created
are created by the small businessman,
how many of them had enough money
just to pay the mortgage and
their rental on their machinery
or their restaurant?
They're not gonna be able
to open up, they're running
on about a 5% margin.
How many of those restaurants
are going to be able to,
A, hold two months, or a month and 1/2,
then open back up when, I
don't know about you Dave,
but I'm not gonna be going running out
to crowded restaurants right away?
That's the last thing
that people are gonna do.
This is going to affect
us enormously, enormously.
- So, yeah.
- And there's something else.
Go ahead, go ahead.
- Well, no, so with that in mind,
so before we get to some of the stuff
that was done wrong, what would be
the right thing to do right now?
So if we're concerned about
all those small businesses,
I mean, I know you're not
necessarily you a UBI guy,
you don't want the government to just be
handing cash to people.
- No.
- But what is the right thing to do, then,
in a situation like this?
- So I'm not a UBI guy
and I've done a lotta looking into UBI
because I know what's
coming with technology
and everything else and
I'm much more of a futurist
than a now-est, if you will.
And so I have looked into
UBI, it doesn't work.
However, this is a different situation.
I'm not talking about
universal basic income,
but this is a different situation.
The crash of 'O8 was
caused by many things,
but the government and the banks
and then stupid people listening
to the government and the banks.
That's why that was
caused, that and greed,
it just caused that thing to melt down.
It wasn't my fault.
Why was I bailing out the banks?
It wasn't your fault, Dave.
Why were you bailing out the banks?
This is different.
Nothing anyone did, except
for China, caused this.
The government turned it off
for the first time in history
and said, "You cannot go to work."
Well, Article Five of
the Constitution says,
"You better give me some money
"because you've just destroyed me.
"So you have to make me as
whole as you possibly can."
So I am for, in this particular case,
the government coming up
with ways to feed money
into the system and help
those at the lowest rung
of the ladder, including
those small businessmen
who are just barely making it,
now you've destroyed them.
Instead what we've done
is we've taken $7,500
from every American, or
16,500 from every taxpayer,
$16,000 from every taxpayer,
and then given some of those taxpayers
a check for $1,200, that's not helping.
We've taken two and 1/2 trillion dollars
and only given 355 billion
to small businesses.
Where's the rest going?
Same place it went last time.
- Right, so with that
in mind, is this just
one of these things where
our system is so broken
in so many ways that every
time we try to do something
to fix it, we just create more problems?
Yeah, we extend it, so we survive 2008,
but then banks are too big to fail,
what do we do?
We make 'em bigger.
That we just create Band-Aid,
on top of Band-Aid, on top of Band-Aid,
when my hope is that this thing
is so profoundly different
that maybe it actually will get people
to look at the root causes
and think about it all differently,
do you think there's any
chance or am I just a dreamer?
- I think you're a dreamer on that one
because the damage has already been done
and the system is already changed.
I think it's been baked into the response.
The fed had prepared this,
this was a prepared
response, you can read it
in their own notes, they knew
exactly what they were doing,
when they came in to the president
and he said, "We've gotta
quarantine the country,
"what do we do,"
the fed handed him a book and said,
"Here's what we think should be done."
They had already war
gamed this to some degree
and so the change was
already baked into it.
Let me give you some stats.
The Federal Reserve is
purchasing 625 billion dollars
per week of US treasury
bonds, that's our debt,
plus US municipal bonds, our city bonds
and our corporate bonds.
At that rate of spend, the Federal Reserve
will own all outstanding US public debt,
federal and local, by
September of this year
and all corporate debt
by December of this year.
They are now pledging 200
billion dollars a month
to US Banks plus Fannie and Freddie
to buy all stressed mortgages.
They are officially, today,
not in the future, today,
the largest landlord in the world.
By the end of the year,
they own almost everything.
So where do you go for a free market?
Deutsche Bank just said over the weekend,
a few days ago, that it was
the end of the free market.
Because of the Federal Reserve,
there is no free market.
And the bad thing is it's not the Fed,
the fed just did all
this behind closed doors.
Did it without discussing,
did it without any members
of Congress being involved
and our treasury is the one
that guarantees everything.
So when they all go bad,
it's on the taxpayer again.
We are propping up the world as a taxpayer
and none of us have been consulted.
It's really, really
dangerous, really dangerous.
- So there's so much stuff there,
but so for the average person
that they hear the Fed,
they hear the numbers
you just lay out, they hear debt to China,
all of these things that,
you're the average person,
you maybe have a job,
maybe don't right now
and you're trying to figure
out how to live your life,
but you wanna pay some
level of attention to this,
well, what do you do?
I mean, what could we have done
or what could we do now
to reverse any of this?
And if Trump was there
to drain the swamp, did
he just utterly fail then?
- No, I don't think he, I mean,
you can't shut the engines off
without juicing the system.
You had to put the money in.
If your choice was tell
everybody to stay home,
you had to juice the system.
The problem is, I think, we
took some of the wrong steps.
I think listening to the Federal Reserve
and to the five biggest
banks in the world,
they were the ones that
got all of the candy.
Meanwhile, they are
making it more difficult,
just as they did in 2008,
for people to go get a mortgage.
You need the average person
to be able to have money.
Instead, why didn't we say
to the banks, "You know what?
"You guys got bailed out last time,
"no mortgage payments for anyone,
"business or home, no mortgage
payments for three months,
"no college student
loans, no loan payments
"for college students for three months?"
All of these things should
have been suspended.
Instead, people who can't pay their rent
are getting a check for $1,200.
Well, in New York, that's not gonna do it.
$1,200 is nothing in New York, nothing.
Won't pay for your
food in New York.
- $1,200,
for a little perspective,
My sister who lives in New York City,
although she's not there now,
lives in a one-bedroom
converted into a two,
so it's a fake two-bedroom apartment,
the rent's around five grand a month.
So yeah, just to give a little
perspective on that 1,200.
So what do we do?
So the libertarian classically
liberal minded people
that are hearing, "Okay, so the Fed,
"all of this stuff is happening,
"it's just solving problems
that they created,"
the rest of it, what
should the states be doing?
So you mentioned, you've
got Abbott there in Texas,
he's doing it, seemingly,
trying to protect
some of your civil liberties,
I've got a different problem here
with Gavin Newsom in California,
but how do we decide, in a time like this,
what the states verse
the fed should be doing?
I wish we were having more
of a conversation about this.
- I do, too.
- It's pretty rare,
and I don't know, did you happen to see
that crazy tweet by CNN's
sources, Brian Stelter,
who had this anonymous source
that told him that Trump's
leaving it up to the governors
as if that somehow scary?
I mean, I would prefer that the governors
have more choice, but how do
you decide intellectually?
- It is the way
the Constitution is written.
It's crazy, look at these
people, look at these people.
"He's leaving it up to
the governors to decide.
"That guy's a total fascist."
- (laughing)
- What, no,
that's the way it's supposed to be.
Everyone who was so concerned
that he would grab power,
when he doesn't tell manufacturing
what to make, they freak out.
I don't know, maybe your
definition of fascist
is the opposite of mine,
but that's what the
president should be doing,
saying, "No, I'm not gonna
take over corporations
"and tell them what to do.
"I'm going to ask them.
"I'm not gonna tell, I'm not
gonna tell states what to do."
And you know what?
Honestly, the governors
should not be telling
the local cities what to do.
The mayor's should say, "In our town,
"this is what's right,
in our village, our city,
"this is what's right and the
governor can help coordinate."
It's always power to the people.
The closer you get to the house,
the more important it becomes.
How is Donald Trump the bad guy here?
- Yeah, but what do you say to the people?
'Cause I hear it all the time, Glenn,
'cause you're singing my tune,
I say these types of things
and that people say, "Well,
if you leave it all up
"to the local officials,
"one city might be doing the right thing,
"but the city next door might
be doing something terrible
"and we know viruses
don't care about borders
"and things like that,"
how do you manage that then?
- "The virus doesn't care about borders,"
of course, it does, why would we stop
all air travel from China?
Of course, it does,
you just have to defend
your border as a town.
If somebody, the town next to you,
well, then you're not coming
into our town, I'm sorry.
I don't know how to do it,
but it's an imperfect system,
as Winston Churchill said,
(coughing) "It's the worst system
"except for everything else."
So I mean, it's not a perfect system
by any stretch of the imagination,
but you have to trust the people.
It is the people, it is their rights.
I just saw a video of
someone being shut down
and the police officer saying,
"Your rights have been suspended."
- Yeah, saw it.
- My rights have been
suspended, how do you
suspend inalienable rights?
Oh, I know, you can't.
(fingers clicking)
You can't suspend rights.
You can, say, for health purposes,
but only the state can do that,
not the Federal Government.
- And by the way, what the guy was doing
was sitting in his car,
where they were gonna
have church services,
where they were all gonna
be socially distanced
from each other, so it wasn't even as if
they were violating, yeah.
- In the car,
with the windows rolled up,
with the windows rolled up.
- How afraid are you, generally,
that we're just gonna keep giving away
these things, that the time, the calendar,
will keep marching and slowly,
yeah, we won't go in our cars,
we won't leave our house,
suddenly walking your
dog will be a problem
and it can only go in the backyard,
or just the endless cascade of
things that we can think of?
But I'm more worried about the things
that we can't think of
that they could come for.
- So here's the worst part.
In the book, Arguing With
Socialists, you have a copy there.
- I've got it here.
- Open it up to Chapter Six.
Yeah, open it up to Chapter Six.
- Okay.
- I don't know if you
saw that one, but it's How Technology
and Modern Monetary Theory
Can Make Socialism More
Dangerous Than Ever.
This was this was assuming
that the economic collapse
would come over a slow
long period of time,
that the economic collapse
and joblessness would happen
maybe because of technology.
In that chapter, I outline
what happens in that situation
where it's lots of joblessness.
The first thing that happens
is the government needs
to spend more money
and so they start to print more money.
Printed in the last few
weeks, more money than we,
we digitized more money than
we could've printed in a year,
you literally could not print,
there's not enough trees to
print the amount of money
that we have just digitized
in a two or three-week period.
- [Dave] So literally, it's
not about the gold anymore,
it's not even about the dollars
'cause we can't print 'em fast enough,
now we're just truly in a,
sort of, imaginary situation.
- So it is called modern monetary theory.
Have you ever heard of it, Dave?
- I haven't,
I'm a simple man, Glenn.
- Okay, this is a huge.
No, no, no, most people don't know it.
It's a huge talking point for socialists
and here's why, because
they've always been held
to this standard of,
"Well, how are you going to pay for it?"
So modern monetary theory is,
"Well, we'll just digitize
or print the money."
"Well, that sounds like old,
failed monetary policy."
"But this is new and the idea
"is that as long as everybody understands
"that we can just print the
money and if we need the money,
"we're gonna have to
tax everybody to death,
"but we're not gonna need the money.
"So we'll just make the money
"and then we'll spend the money
"and that will help us make more money,"
modern monetary theory.
"And if there's inflation,
"we'll use price controls
"and we'll also use taxes
to make sure that people
"are buying only the things
that we want them to buy."
This is total control of an
economy, through a government,
through the printing of dollars,
that's modern monetary theory.
The fed is doing it right now,
but the UK treasury, the Crown,
just announced that they are
using modern monetary theory
and they are actually just printing the,
they're, at least, admitting it.
We're doing it as well.
In this chapter, I talk about,
when that starts, the
government is going to know
it needs tech and tech will
know it needs the government.
And so tech and the government
will start to work
together to monitor people
because they'll need to monitor and track,
et cetera, et cetera.
The coronavirus has made
Chapter Six a reality.
You asked me, "How nervous are you?"
I'm terrified that what
I wrote in Chapter Six
is happening right now.
- (sighing) Okay, so
there's so much there.
So jumping from that,
which will lead us further
into the book, so how much of this,
the situation that we're in right now,
do you think was just because our systems
were collapsing in front of us?
We were watching the media
system collapse in front of us,
we were watching academia
collapse in front of us,
we were watching the political
establishment collapse
and that all of those collapses
and then you find a
crisis that you can throw
in the middle of that,
lead to this perfect stew,
where suddenly numbers
don't even mean anything
and we have new monetary policy.
- Okay, (coughing) so let me
let me answer it this way.
You know the Reichstag fire?
- Of course, never let a good crisis
go to waste.
- Okay,
correct, now, let's separate
this from what we know,
let me give you two answers on this.
One, the Germans said that
that fire was happening
and then the Nazis just
took advantage of it,
that's one version.
The other version is, no, they started it,
they wanted it to burn and
then they used that fire.
So I don't think that that
is what happened here.
I don't think anyone started this fire.
I don't think, while I do
believe that this did come
from bats, that the specimens
were collected by the Chinese
and brought to that lab,
it was not released
intentionally, it was sloppy.
So nobody created this crisis
and then it's a series of events
that just spiral out of control.
But I do believe, at some point,
somebody came in and went,
"You know, this whole thing
is melting down anyway,
"this might be a good time
just up pull the plug."
I do think that's a possibility.
- (sighing) Man.
- Either that,
or we just have the
craziest people in charge.
- Yeah, it's weird
because we all, sort of,
become conspiracy theorists
and then it's like, "Well,
what's really a conspiracy?"
'Cause what you're saying is,
it's not that it's some
coordinated thing necessarily,
but events transpire
and feed off each other
and next thing you know, here we are.
- And you not only have
events feed off each other,
you do have bad actors.
For instance, China is now telling France,
"We can help you out all you want,
"but you have to take our 5G systems.
"We'll give you all the
masks that you need,
"but we'll only sell
'em to you if you do."
So you have bad actors doing that
and I do think that there are those
who are in global positions,
be them people that are in high tech,
or in high finance, or governments,
that do want a different system,
that don't believe in
the system of the West
and they would like to use
an opportunity to their advantage.
I don't think it's a conspiracy theory
to think that people actually believe,
don't let a crisis go to waste,
especially since many
people in positions of power
have been saying it out loud recently.
If you look at what the Fabian Socialists
did in World War One, we
wouldn't have gone to war
if there weren't a group
of people that were saying,
"This is actually, work to our advantage.
"We should go to world war
"'cause we can change the world
"closer to our hearts desire."
That's what they did then
and I think it plays some role here.
- So it's interesting because all of this,
actually, is, sort of, directly related
to why you're constantly
arguing with socialists,
but before we get into
the book specifically,
just one more thing on this generally.
What do you make of the role
or the state of media right now?
I know you and I are in agreement
on just watching mainstream
media collapse and in many ways,
it should, but just in
the last couple days,
this insane New York Times
story that defended Biden
because, "There's no evidence,"
even though that wasn't the standard
they held Brett Kavanaugh to.
Or a million other
examples I can give lately,
of just corona related nonsense
and two months ago it's
not gonna be a problem.
Now, they're screaming, "Fire."
I mean, 'cause that's
another piece of this
that I think has just
run ram shot basically,
across everybody and nobody
knows who to trust right now.
- So it's a crisis of
trust in almost everything.
When I was growing up,
we were in the Cold War
with the Soviet Union
and I remember thing, as a kid,
"How could anyone believe Pravda?
"How could anybody believe that stuff?"
The answer turns out to be,
pretty easily, they can believe that
because they want to,
or they're invested in believing that.
To turn around and say, "Ooh, my side,
"I've been on the wrong side,"
takes a really honest person,
Dave Rubin.
- (laughing)
- Takes somebody who has real guts.
And it's rare, at least,
early on, it's rare.
The people who are
reading the New York Times
or watching CNN and all of this garbage,
they are so deep into it now
and if you watch the media,
how many of them are saying,
in fact, I just saw
something here, a minute ago,
about how the press is
yelling at Donald Trump
because he wants to open the country up
and he wants to tell all
these states, "Open up."
Okay, but they were yelling at him
when he wouldn't close all of the states
because he said, "It's the
states that should decide."
So now, he's kinda flip-flopped,
but it's interesting
that they only wanted him
to take the power to control, now,
to keep it closed, not to
open it up, keep it closed.
It's astounding to me, watching the press,
how they're almost wanting more death,
more destruction, more
bad things to happen,
because the only loser really
is Donald Trump, in their eyes.
"To hell with the country,
to hell with freedom,
"to hell with all of this stuff,
"if Donald Trump, if he
likes it, it's gotta be bad,
"if he's against it, it's gotta be good."
And they'll do anything,
anything, it's beyond
Trump derangement syndrome
as a t-shirt slogan,
it is a real, true, deep illness.
- Yeah, see, I'm with you on this.
And I've asked a couple of guests this
and they've said, that no,
they don't really wanna crash
the economy, defeat Trump.
But I actually think, you may remember,
about a year, a year and 1/2 ago,
when Bill Maher said he
would gladly tank the economy
to get rid of trump if that's
what it takes.
- Oh, yeah.
- And I do think that
the media establishment.
- Oh, I do.
- They've gone in so deep,
it's like they're the boy who cried wolf
and it's like, well, you missed Russia,
you missed Ukraine,
impeachment, blah, blah, blah.
And it's like, now, they
see blood in the water
and I think they almost have
to take it as far as it can go
to prove that they're not crazy,
it's something like that.
- Yeah, they want this to be true.
They want this to be true.
How they can say he's a fascist
and then yell at him when he
doesn't move like a fascist
is crazy, is crazy.
- Well, Glenn, don't forget.
- You've gone over the edge.
- Don't forget, the
other flip side of that
is they'll say, "He's Hitler,"
and then they'll say,
"He's not doing enough."
I mean, it's like both sides of this coin
don't work.
- That's what I mean, yeah.
You can't have it both ways.
Their hatred for Donald Trump
is greater than their love of country.
Now, they can say that
they love their country
because they're fighting Donald Trump,
but they're not seeing,
it's somebody who is so
enraged, I'm trying to think
of a movie where I've seen this,
where the person might even
have righteous indignation,
where they're just so enraged
and they're just acting
and now they're starting
to hurt everything
and people have to grab them and say,
"Stop it, stop, stop."
Nobody's grabbing them,
nobody's stopping them.
- Glenn, I know you could do
Star Wars all day with me,
how about Anakin Skywalker on Mustafar
when he chokes Padme, right?
And then Obi-Wan has the jump in
and it doesn't end that well for Vader.
As long as we're doing Star Wars,
I'll ask you one more thing about corona
and then we're gonna move on to the book.
So I know that you have the original,
I think there are three of them,
you're gonna have to clean this up for me,
three original Darth Vader masks.
If there was ever a time in life
for Glenn Beck to walk
out to the supermarket
wearing Darth Vader's helmet,
this would be that time.
- (laughing)
- Please, tell me
you're doing it.
- It would be.
- Tell me you're doing it,
Glenn, please.
- No, I haven't done that,
but I did see somebody in a
supermarket, here in Texas,
wearing a stormtrooper's mask
and I thought, at first, it was funny,
until she took the mask up
and she had it so the
bottom of the mask was here
and her whole face was out and she's like,
"Phew, I don't know how
these people could breathe
"or even see in these things."
She was not joking, she
really put that on like,
"This'll protect me."
Oh, my gosh. (laughing)
- It's a costume, lady.
- It's the thinning
of the herd, Dave.
It is the thinning of the herd.
- All right, well, because we're people
that don't necessarily
want the herd to thin out,
let's focus on the book for a little bit.
So I told you right before we started
that I got the book just a couple days ago
and this weekend, I had
it on my coffee table
and just every couple hours,
I would pick it up, read
a couple pages, it's fun.
- Thank you.
- You actually wrote
about politics in a fun, with
cartoons and little memes
and images and all this stuff,
you wrote about some pretty serious stuff
in an actual fun way.
So my first question really
is, was that the plan?
Like, "Oh, everyone's
getting drubbed over the head
"with all this stuff endlessly,
"why not give them something
that it's not like."
'Cause actually, in many ways,
this book is not designed
to read in one sit down
or over three nights,
it's sort of designed to pick it up,
think about something, put
it down and do it again.
- So I'm riddled with
ADD and it's hard for me,
especially nonfiction, I can read fiction,
nonfiction, especially when it's boring
or it's got numbers involved
and you're talking about
economics and everything,
you're like, "Aw, shut up,"
and I just can't get through them.
And so what I did was we patten a book
called Arguing With Idiots
and I know this is a little redundant,
but Arguing With Idiots,
I wrote about 10 years ago
and I heard from so many people
who are now in their
20s and 30s that said,
"When that came out, I loved that book
"and I used the 100 pages
at the end of the footnotes
"to go back and I wrote papers on it,
"or I used it as arguments,
but I didn't quote you."
That's brilliant, that's
exactly what has to happen.
I went in, if we found
something, a stat or something,
and we had it verified by
the Heritage Foundation,
I would go back and say,
"Find a lefty organization,
"find the New York Times verifying this,
"because you need the argument
that they will accept,
"they're not gonna accept
the Heritage Foundation.
And so it was an easy way to read it.
It's a fun way to read it, exactly right,
I have not said this out loud,
but I think it's more of a bathroom book.
- (laughing)
- It's one of those
that you put in the
bathroom and you pick it up
and you enjoy reading it
and you could pick it up on any page,
but I did it so those with open minds
could actually see the best
arguments on both sides
and do it in a fun way.
- So one of the things that's
really interesting to me
is that, in the last couple weeks,
as Bernie sputtered and
now has dropped out,
there's been a bunch of tweets by people,
high-level people, from his campaign,
I think one of them was a
deputy campaign manager,
who tweeted out, "Oh, finally,
we can drop democratic
"from democratic socialism."
Now, I've been screaming
this for three years
that this is the plan.
They're sneaking it in,
they're sneaking in the bomb
and then once it's in, they'll unleash it
and of course they were gonna drop it.
Are you surprised how
brazenly they've dropped it?
And not only that, but the
second part of this will be,
do you think they have to
destroy Bernie in the process now
because he didn't win,
he didn't get them there
and ultimately, he'll just
be an old rich white man
who played by the rules so
that he has to be sacrificed
at the altar of their socialist
god or whatever it is?
- Maybe, because it's just such
a destructive god that maybe.
I think there's a chance
he becomes Barry Goldwater,
that gave birth to the
Reagan movement years later.
I don't think he was the one
to bring it to its finish,
that person remains to be seen yet.
When it comes to whether
it's, I can't remember,
what was the other part
of your question, Dave?
I'm sorry, I should've written it down.
- Well, so first, whether
they designed this
to destroy Bernie.
- I don't think so.
- Wait, what was
the first part? (laughing)
Right, so whether they.
- Yeah, I don't remember.
- Oh, oh, but dropping
democratic socialism
really just as an idea itself.
- Oh, dropping democratic.
Yeah, democratic socialism is crazy.
First, I really believe
that it was not Stalin,
but Lenin who first used
the democratic socialists
because they were afraid of communists,
the Russians were afraid
of the communists.
And he said, "No, no,
no, we're democratic,
"we're democratic socialists."
And so it's been a ruse
from the very beginning.
When I was at Fox,
I remember there was a
US News & World Report
that was a magazine when
there were magazines
and it had on the cover,
about three months into
Barack Obama's term,
it said, "We're all socialists now."
And I remember holding that
up on camera and saying,
"First of all, I didn't
think you were socialists,
"second of all, what sort
of bubble do you live in
"where you can declare
for the entire country,
"'We're all socialists now'?"
And I used that to say
they are dying to tell you
who they really are,
they've been living undercover for so long
and they've waiting for
their moment for so long
that at some point the
mask is gonna come off,
say, "Damn right, because
this system doesn't work,"
and that's where we're at.
We're at the, "Damn right."
- So was that it?
- "Yeah, we are socialists."
- So is that it,
that they are frothing at the mouth now?
You can feel there's a
certain excitement right now
from AOC and Ilhan Omar and
you also have Elizabeth Warren,
who's been a little
more quiet during this,
and Bernie, those are
the four on the cover.
But with AOC and Ilhan Omar,
there's a real frothing at the mouth,
a real excitement right now, like,
"See, none of it works."
AOC had this tweet about
late-stage capitalism,
showing people in lines at
supermarkets in San Antonio,
what she always fails to add is that,
yeah, our stores still get restocked,
unlike in socialist countries.
And that, as you said before, it's messy,
nothing in a free society
is absolutely perfect.
But, yes, I do see that,
the mask is dropping now.
And so that leads me to
are they really just communists, actually,
that the next mask that
drops is the socialist mask,
meaning that they won't even have to
do it through the system?
- No, so this is something
that I clear up in the
first chapter of the book.
Communism is not the bad one, (laughing)
if you actually look at
the theories of Marx,
communism is the utopia.
We've switched these, it was
the Soviet Socialist Republic.
Okay, it's the socialist
side that is the scary side,
the communism only happens
when we all live in a happy commune
and we're all saying, "Oh, you know what?"
"I'll give you my stuff,
don't worry about it,"
and there's no big boss, there's no guns
because you don't need it because everyone
has come to this communist or commune idea
and we all wanna be there.
So communism is the utopia,
socialism is the step between,
when you have capitalists
and then you have the people who say,
"I want this utopia,"
it's this middle part.
Well, you're gonna have to do something
to convince these people
who like capitalism
that you wanna be over here.
And so you slowly drag
them in, piece by piece,
and then, at some point,
you just have to shoot
all the other people
that don't agree with it so
we can get to the happy place.
So they're not communists,
they are brutal socialists
that are willing to kill,
willing to do whatever it takes,
because the ends justify the means.
- I mean, this is what
I keep describing as
this is Thanos from The Avengers movies.
- What did he have to do?
- It is.
- He had to wipe out 1/2
the people in the universe
to create the utopia.
As he said, "I'm the good guy
"because I was the only
one brave enough to do it."
- And can I ask you something, Dave?
- Yeah.
- You live in Hollywood.
- I apologize.
- Do these people even
watch some of the stuff that they make?
Especially when it comes to Marvel,
I watch these things and I'm like, "Right,
"I mean, it's not just me, right,
"you're seeing that this is
making the freedom message here.
"It's making all of the conservative
"or the libertarian point here, right?"
Do they read, I'll actually
just leave it at that,
do they read?
- Well, you know what,
I think you know this,
as someone that's been around the block,
a lot of the people here in
Hollywood, which is very much
changing right now and
I think after corona,
the idea of celebrity and
these big budget things,
I think that this is all gonna change.
But you know, most of
these people, privately,
of course, they're capitalists
and more libertarian
minded and everything else.
They push nonsense in a confused message,
while in their own lives,
what do they wanna do
more than anything else?
They wanna be free, they
wanna earn their money,
they wanna spend it freely,
but they push a message to everybody else,
it's like most of our politicians,
that's just counter to
the way they actually act.
Can you believe it, Glenn?
- Yes.
- Could you actually
believe that?
- It's amazing, I have
talked to some studio heads,
so these are the big bosses
and they are definitely capitalists.
And they said, "If Bernie
Sanders is the guy,
"all of us are gonna be
voting for Donald Trump.
"We'll never say that
because all the actors
"and actresses, they all
believe in this crap,
"but they'll kill this industry,
"he would kill this industry."
And so I know there are
some capitalists out there,
they're not libertarians or conservatives,
but they do like their money.
And they know what socialism does.
- Exactly, all right,
so if you're gonna argue
with a socialist, I'm gonna ask you
probably the number one
question that I get asked
when I go to college campuses,
which is how do you even
initiate the conversation,
not if you're Glenn Beck,
right, not if you're Dave Rubin,
but if you're a young
kid on a college campus
and the terrible ideas
that you write about here
are taking root and many of your friends
have subscribed to them
and you just wanna talk to them
about freedom a little bit,
some of this, but they are
automatically gonna call you
a Nazi and a racist and all of that stuff,
what is a trick, have
you learned any tricks
throughout this that would
allow the conversation
to even get to an argument?
- So that's the part, yes.
Yes, so that was a key word,
a key word, Dave, trick.
It cannot be a trick.
It cannot be a smooth move.
Let me put this in, I
know you're agnostic or,
are you an atheist or an agnostic?
- Glenn, you're gonna really enjoy
this other book I have sitting here
because I'm going to talk
about some things in a new way.
(laughing) I would say, yeah.
- Okay, all right.
Go ahead.
- I would say,
I'm a functional believer,
I would say, at this point,
sort of, in the Jordan
Peterson sense of it.
- Okay, good.
- That, yeah,
we'll discuss this.
- Good for you, good for you,
okay, that's good.
Okay, well, let me just talk to you here
about Jesus for a second and one thing
that I don't like about Christian church,
let me just take on my church,
we have missionaries that go out
and I don't mind the idea of missionaries
and talking to people about things,
but what bothers me is,
"How do we get people
"to talk about Jesus, how do we get people
"to get closer to baptism?"
I don't know, that sounds icky.
How about we love people
and we listen to people
and we seek out what they are
looking for in their life.
What are they seeking?
Most socialists, I think,
the ones who have not
really thought it through,
I'm not talking about the die hard,
well, at least, most diehards.
I'm talking about the people who are in it
because they see a system, they were born
and maybe their first
memory is September 11th
and they remember the
carnage and the chaos
and it had stuff to do
about big war machines
and it was about oil and money and,
"My dad might have lost his job,
"or the stock market shut
down and it was scary,
"then my next big memory is 2008
"and my mom and dad lost everything
"that they had worked hard for
"and had to start all over again
"and then coronavirus hit
and they lost everything.
"This system doesn't work,
this system is only rewarding
"the really powerful and the rich.
"My folks struggled and I
don't wanna live my life
"like my folks did,
believing in this nonsense."
That, if I heard somebody
talk to me about that,
I could relate to them
and I would agree with almost
everything they just said.
Now, we can have a conversation
because instead of approaching them
and trying to win the argument,
I'm trying to ask them questions
to get to understand their perspective.
How did they get there?
"Don't talk to me about systems,
"how did you get here, what
are you really looking for?"
And if you're looking for,
"The workers of the
world unite," I move on.
If you're looking to find a better way
to live in harmony, live
some natural principles,
live in ways that will actually work
and, "I don't see this system is working,"
okay, great, I'm with you.
So now, what are the problems?
Let's separate the baby
from the bath water.
Is there a baby in that bath water?
I think there is, you may not,
so let's define what that baby is
and separated from the bathwater.
- Yeah, I guess, the only
problem there is that.
- Does that make sense?
- Well, of course, it makes sense,
but, I guess, the only
flaw, unfortunately,
is that we have just so many young people
that talk about workers
of the world unite,
or just the evil patriarchy,
or just the simple versions
as opposed to a complex human version
of understandable things
that you just laid out there,
that it makes that
conversation just hard to have.
- Well, it makes it
hard to have in a crowd,
but nothing is ever
really solved in a crowd.
Everyone wants to be heard.
Everyone wants to be listened to,
nobody wants to be listening to somebody
who's just waiting for the opportunity
to spring their good news on them.
We have to empathize
and really truly listen
or we're not gonna make any
inroads and mainly because
a lot of the people who are arguing it,
they don't even know what
they're talking about.
So many people on our side
are just spouting stuff
that they heard from somebody else
and they haven't thought it through.
We don't need a bunch of followers,
we need leaders, we need to find people
that really will have a change of heart.
I said to you, Dave, two years ago,
we were talking about something
and we disagreed on it
and I said, "I think I know
you well enough to know
"that you'll get there, you'll get there
"because it only makes logical sense."
And you may have agreed
with me at that time,
kind of, half-heartedly and said,
"Yeah, I could see that maybe happening."
And that's because I
respect your intellect
and there are things that
are universally true.
We can look at it in different ways,
we can argue it in different ways,
but when it comes down to it,
if you have a few things
as your guiding principles,
you will eventually
find your way down here.
That's what we need to find.
- Yeah, well, you know
what I'd love to do, I
know, in a couple weeks
when I'm gonna be on your
show to talk about my book,
I lay out all of these principles
and we do have some disagreements
on some of these things
and we could spend, let's do it,
let's spend the entire conversation
discussing only the things we disagree on,
it'll actually be pretty
beautiful 'cause I know there's
a couple of points in there.
- I'd love that.
- That you're not gonna agree with.
But how much of this, also, is that
when you when you have a cover like this
and you put these people
that, it's a cartoon,
but they sort of are cartoon characters.
AOC, Ilhan Omar, Tlaib's not on the cover,
but a bunch of these, the squad,
they really do seem
like cartoon characters
and it makes sense that people like them
wanna get into politics
because their whole ethos
is about controlling people,
even if it's presented
as freeing people, as
opposed to what, I think,
our side would roughly be,
which is about freeing people,
you're not really gonna
want to get into politics.
It's a much harder sell
to get a strong person,
who doesn't wanna rule your
life, to get into politics,
which is about ruling people's lives.
So there's an asymmetry
of the types of people
fighting for these political positions.
- Yes, and it's a problem,
libertarians are like herding cats,
conservatives, generally
speaking, not all of them,
but generally speaking, they
have an entrepreneurial spirit
and so they just go do their thing
and those who see society as a collective,
they're on the left and they're raised
and groomed themselves to be
somebody who's a busybody,
who's caring about
everybody else's business
and so they have to be
in charge of something.
And so they do, it's a
lopsided scenario here.
But it's interesting you bring
up their cartoon characters
and they are cartoons,
but if you look, so am I.
- (laughing)
- And this is a statement,
really, from the last book
was Arguing With Idiots
and I don't know if you
remember that cover,
but I had dark eye makeup on
to make me look really crazy
and I was in, it was a Russian uniform
and I was standing like a dictator.
And I remember, I walked into Fox News
when that book came out
and Roger Ailes held the book up and said,
"Why the hell would you
ever look like this?
"Why would you ever put that picture out?"
And I said, "Because that's the
way half the country sees me
"and I wanna poke fun at myself
"'cause they see me as a cartoon character
"and they have to stop seeing
me and others like cartoons."
So it's kinda the same thing,
the facts in here are not cartoons,
but the exaggerations
by these eco-socialist,
that we're all gonna die in
12 years, that is cartoon,
that is a cartoon.
- So I was actually
gonna ask you about that.
- The facts are not.
- Can you talk about why
they use that as a tactic,
this, sort of, everything is collapsing
and it's collapsing now?
It's all always about 12 years from now
and five months from now
and you've a funny thing
with AOC and the cow farts
because we have to
rejigger everything now,
otherwise mass death is coming.
- So here's what is,
it's the only reason and the only way
to get socialism to be as popular as it is
in a country as wealthy and
where the poorest among us
are in the top 1% of the world,
you have to create other problems.
In the last two years, we have
had fewer deaths per capita
than any time in American history.
We have had more jobs
and a higher percentage,
or I should say, a lower percentage
of unemployment than ever before,
at least, in the last 100 years.
We have it really, really good.
I mean, people who are,
quote-unquote, poor, have iPhones.
You're not poor and have a
phone, let alone an iPhone,
so you have to create a boogeyman.
And the left always says
that that's what the right
does with terrorists,
or with communists in Russia, or whatever,
that it's just a boogeyman, it's not real.
So they'll deny real killers,
in many cases, they will
embrace them, Fidel Castro,
even Hitler, Mussolini, they
were all embraced by the left.
And they will come up with
these boogeymen to be able to
frighten us because you have
to have something to save.
It's about forcing people to do something
because, "It's right for the collective,
"they just are not smart enough to see it,
"so we need your help to
round these people up,
"to try to convince them, but, damn,
"they just won't see the
error of their ways."
Well, that goes into the
idea of socialism, too,
that a few elites know
better and you're one of 'em,
you just know better.
- All right.
- That's how it works.
- All right, so taken, yeah, go ahead.
- What's frightening is how far we went
under a good economy.
If we are, indeed, going
to hit 30% unemployment,
as the Federal Reserve
says, 32.4% unemployment
is what they predict by June 1st,
if we get anywhere close to that
and it doesn't turn around when
we turn the engines back on,
Dave, we are going to be, I
made this prediction in 2008,
if we go down this road,
we will make Hitler look like rookies
because we are a great
nation with great power
and if we go dark, we will use that power
in ways that the world has never seen.
I shudder to think what we
will do to our own people
and to the rest of the world
with great power and dark
collective forces in charge.
- Oh, man, well, if that answer
was the shutting off the engine answer,
now, to wrap this whole thing up,
give me some hope here, give me the answer
that the engine can get on and functional
before we hit rock bottom.
- Yeah, it's an easy one.
We just have to remember that
our right are inalienable,
meaning no man can change them,
we don't get them from men,
we don't get them from the government,
you can't suspend my rights,
I have inalienable rights.
When we remember who we are, we can take,
if I were on an island
and I had to pick a team
from a country to help me
put together airplane parts
that are just scattered all over a field
and make some form of transportation,
I would pick the Americans
every single time.
We will figure out a
way, the Enigma machine,
which was the unbreakable
code of the Germans
and there was a great movie
out about the Turing test
and Alan Turing, who was this
great, great, brilliant mind,
broke it in, I think, two or
three years, it took them,
and they had an Enigma machine.
What isn't told is that two
Americans on a Navy ship
in the Pacific didn't have
a machine and figured out
and broke that in about six months.
So Americans figure things out.
We're just good at that, it's
that entrepreneurial spirit,
if given the chance,
when this thing opens up,
the cure, or the
treatment, or the testing,
or whatever it is that we need,
will come from, I think,
either Israel or the
United States of America.
The answers will come to rebuild,
the technology will be there
and the spirit will be there
if we don't allow the
media and quite honestly,
those who are so eager to control people
that they kick the snot out of our spirit,
over and over again, we're
not only gonna survive,
we'll thrive, we'll thrive
'cause that's what we do.
- I'm with ya', Beck, our
work is cut out for us,
but I don't have anything
better to do, do you?
- I don't either, I'm not
gonna spend the rest of my life
not doing that.
- Exactly, all right, well,
we're gonna put a link
to the book right down below.
Stay safe and one of these
days we'll get to do this
in person again.
- I'll talk to you
in a couple weeks.
- Yeah.
- I know,
I'll talk to you in a couple weeks,
when your book comes out.
I can't wait, send it to me
so I can read it in advance.
- We're gonna get one out to you, today.
All right, good seeing you, my friend.
- Good, thanks.
- If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of non stop yelling,
check out our Politics playlist
and if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our Full Episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.